this is a production of Cornell
University it's not only the busiest
even my son
EF season on a theme park reader so
artist Holly gave my green version right
now so your apology like that but it's
also the meet when we've been kind
hearted days these part next those who
are not in Seneca Falls so my readers
reason were for max what is incentive
all is acceptable by the circles around
the lake
releasing the fibroid all right
will terminate in the lightning tour
here on this topic I find this uh Cooper
those genes my food has been a nod to a
talk I think many years ago on this
topic essentially two others written up
to a garden club that legal - lady star
club they were very curious very
appreciative audience
[Music]
[Music]
I think that helps us all important way
to talk about it with other people I
will go through what is genetic
engineering and try to put it in the
context of previous and changing our
therapy program and then we'll address a
few of what could be making question
concerns and it won't be about starting
to talk about everything but I hope to
hit someone is that relevant to this
particular audience so why did much
university but when a Christian and
engineer crux was grown commercially
issues in the mid-1990s around 20 years
ago now a lot of the people involved the
industry decision industry as well as
the breeders said oh this is just a
logical extension what managers have
always time those people have never
heard of thank you Frank
I thought when I came to Cornell so that
tells you something
so there's
okay so about 2/3 of the people sent
down there go another 11% we're not sure
and a little over a quarter said yes and
there's always we recognize that the
answers should look like that and the
line there is maybe that's not just a
circle it's a quite right
this is just easily
[Music]
we have concerns we all support
population will always have concerns
sometimes genetic engineering a new tool
for breeding improved crops which is a
process that dates back to domestication
by this way humans first began taxes and
years ago tinkering with the genetics of
the crops we grow by choosing which
seats to save
of course you know Gregor Mendel the
early readers and our we stood through
who I'm about to go to the nursery to
exactly the same design be sexy
thirty's some augmented by that thing
which this machine gonna do tonight
engineering the best way you want the
message that you have to illustrate what
that difference means was something that
a colleague at the University of
Lausanne put together which one these
images james madison wisconsin art from
the mid 1600s and its current a
professional so we looked at this old
still life paintings you know the Dutch
masters and all that there is what a
watermelon look like in mid 1600 on the
left the only way of course is a wonder
than that and you ask what makes it so
much - assistant engineer influences Ole
Miss
well the only company this is a
consistent product of selection and
breeding traditional breeding which of
course right so to put this in context
yes it is a new tool for reading through
Christ but overlaid on the context of
proof families change that he was right
about the genetics of the crops we use
for food the fuel fiber has beauty so
that new tool is a way to change the
properties and artists I wouldn't use
the keyword innocence or actually
exists but in a lady that does not
require sexual cross compatibility I'm
actually a traditional career I live
across my apartment my horn
I think once my initiative is activated
for bacteria and ourselves but I
remember that genetic engineering allows
you to bypass that cross compatibility
barrier to pull a gene from a bacterium
and can see what we put it in a corn
plant okay that's where it's different
let's do the quick review of genetic
material DNA experiment the exodus of
codebook where all the information you
need to do for my TV or our needs to
inform the school it controls the
structure of the organism as well as
when most products are produced it is a
code essentially repeating four letters
four base pairs that form the core of
the scanning molecule we have read even
ad GMC and amazingly enough that more
than our code does provide every
cylinder only all the instructions for
what you need to do every second all the
instructions
please give talks for other conferences
and not too many departments and
ethicists this cohesive member so
imagine that all that approach if you
come for healthy babies or a tentative
or a human or so a tree or wing or lives
every single organism uses essentially
the same government that in personally
is why genetic engineering works someone
could take a gene from that bacteria and
plug it into a soybean plant into the
soybean plant it's just more 80 GS and
C's more instructions so as the
machinery that we coated the soybean
plant comes to that gene
it doesn't say here's something from the
bacteria all that C's is more
instructions written in the same
commitment in Isis and it would be if
Sunil were writing a piece of literature
and said you know this part is grab
there's all the club that lessons
automatic enough so we cut out a piece
that's in exceedingly Don then paste it
in there there nice person that needs
that it's not going to say nearly 2/3
witness it's when the one planet was
all the time okay too quickly new
traditional crossbreeding
across to Paris the offspring like their
kids of a mix of traits from the two
parents genetic engineering that they've
challenged in some ways is to find an
actual gene that would be useful to have
no claims but then hire rather complex
process you stick that gene into your
plan a lot of some sequences that make
sure you it gets expressed whenever you
wanted to so genetic engineering plant
and one pair of people genes and into a
particular parent as opposed to be mates
of the new parents they were crossed to
make a traditional cross traffic light
so genetically produce go all the way
back to the mastication this is my
organism this is its wild ancestor
teosinte not very similar when they
might be partners all will be grown
selected different types of that
organism ease to fit their particular
niches I love this
these are things we think of as
completely different vegetables broccoli
cauliflower kale kohlrabi cabbage
brussel sprouts they all trace back to
exactly the same ancestral mustard
plants different people in different
places selected for different medical
clinic parts and the ward you've got
that poor girl
a large departure platter effects or
leaves or stems or lateral loads like
the Brussels sprouts and of course
traditional cross breeding and genetic
engineering when I say humans have
profoundly altered the genetics of our
Oxford thousands of years this is what I
mean because reading farmers choosing to
save seed to farmers selecting and
savings and cultivated crops to breeding
that's why on 450 years
- gingy so when imagine your crops that
are out there three big categories and a
few less or newer and less on the ground
ones first
et claps which have a gene from what you
thought they all recognized as a
bacterial insecticide the solicitor in
Genesis so this their size and a number
of other things the gene that produces a
protein that inside an insect alkaline
gut is converted kind of man to a toxin
was really from the bacterium and put
into some of these crops to make that
insect resistant you may need to drop
your mind because you have an exit exit
so do all mammals and birds certain
insects I mean did they assume that
protein the gene produces and it becomes
a toxin that alkalyn got environments
and that is what control
secondly Kenworthy herbicide resistant
crops most studies on that already
resistant like say although there are
other site resistances coming along
again this isn't even actually a pretty
soil bacteria that last plan to detoxify
on its underside that would otherwise be
toxic to it and the movie category virus
resistant classy planet and SWAT unit to
the nightmare like this is genetic
engineered virus resistant papaya and
this is compliant that is not resistant
so you can see quite effective
that one is created by taking the gene
that makes the protein coat of the virus
a virus is a protein come with a little
piece of genetic material inside that's
all it is
and in that genetic material is one gene
that produces the protein so the virus
to make itself comes okay you take the
gene to the coat how could you use their
car someplace to get disease you move it
into the plants and it's essentially
like what we do when we get accident it
essentially
against infection that matters so the
plant produces proteins for fighters
members there are few more distinct root
of the medicine elements are one of
those three the BT in the identity or
psychosis and the viruses has been
around for a long time or recently you
have numerous hypotheses about why in a
moment
we have produced women out Batho so this
should develop to be v6 engine stability
is feed we have the potato that's been
engineered for less than this black spot
bruise over here lesson for my
production and like like resistance
several versions of that and we have not
recommended this one together particle
which you can cut them it doesn't right
now I want to sit me you see reduce Lima
not well with a potato and Apple these
are police on the first trips that
strike you as something directed
consumer quality okay the black spot
there's kind of a consumer issue the
acrylamide production
consumer issue the non-driving Apple
more appealing to consumers and the
reduce leaving out the consumers in that
case our past tradition to the
engineering side we haven't even hit
this forehead and I'm not sure I'll have
today I want to talk to this audience
particularly about vegetables fruits of
our dimensions to see you know a lot of
this is in the fields perhaps early huh
but there have been a series of Google's
so when you can approval to
commercialize your genetic engineered
version of the crop from three agencies
the USDA yes part to that question in
order to be sure there's not a new pest
problem created by that car the
Environmental Protection Agency which
was to things like label like the safe
for you son Toxocara killed but they're
genetically engineered resistance okay
so the EPA and the Food and Drug
Administration which is responsible for
food and eating wait not those three
approvals you get what's called
deregulation or approval to
commercialize that Hawk without special
regulations so these are starting
England
all the approvals it's just the number
of approvals in a given year for things
which would be considered vegetable
fruits or ornamental there is a big
space early on the tomato the flavor
secret tomato was actually the first
genetic engineered crop and lots of
different versions of it recruited and
then we're a few young squashes here
those lattice resistance washings
a few potatoes here but papaya had the
virus resistant papaya and then kind of
a desert here until pops resistant plum
another papaya patterns this one right
here is the balloon rose which is been
proven elements we use and then another
reason this is 2014 to 2017
a recent collection that includes that
new version of the particular material
reduces acrylamide black spot personally
light resistance as well as if you are
to happen to preventing contact ii put
some stars on this picture and what the
stars represent is the numbers so this
is the numbers for vegetable fruit
ornamentals the stars are the numbers
from being pressed so you see they
tracked fairly similarly here at the
beginning but then where the the things
that are directly tied to consumers
vegetables fruits
right off we send a lot of field crops
activity really a month and now there's
certain catching up again so I think the
public response costs the people that
are producing fruit vegetables and less
ornamentals I think there's just as much
work there to that well for this
technology because after all we don't
see them ourselves to see but we should
only eat it able to karriesue peppers
and some responsibility through some
questions and concerns there are a lot
of estimates and estimates vary
dramatically so if you talk to you from
the really large seed industry any of
your estimates that include millions of
dollars if you talk to Okanagan
specialty fruits the develop the Arctic
echo that's where exciting company in
Canada they got us approval and then
2,200
so explore the depends on how many where
oh [ __ ] right there is a fair amount of
Hey look at all so it's not if there's
no more than which is stupid so I will I
will say this about crisper so
Christopher is a technology for bringing
about genetic change in a much more
targeted way and the two things that
lets you do differently from traditional
genetic engineering which is cut many
magnificent in that basically somewhere
at random and hoping to find one where
he didn't randomly disrupt genes plant
instruction okay
that's genetic engineering CRISPR allows
you to target exactly where in the
genetic material of that croc who wants
to make a change and then either do one
of two things create random change at
that spot so you identify perhaps who
uses an example
this flower color of those those are the
source ultimately variation we all have
small genetic differences from each
other and those traits like to copy the
scenes most of those are not useful but
here is where you can create a faster
rate of
virgin okay the other thing is a mirror
image of genetic engineering
you can cause a break in a particular
apartment in a but then give the plants
a template that includes a new gene so
that whatever cares that way giving or
it's the new G so this we can be used to
do genetic engineering it can also be
used to create randomly change the
random change what there is nothing you
can measure on those plants it will tell
you this was a result spec to be Chris
burg versus waiting around on
permutations so figure out what to do
with that there is something that can do
actually look at a plant and verify
whether it's a mutation or the USDA is
struggling they're reworking their
regulations right now that is in
question the European Union Justice nest
within the past week decided that yes
Chris Kirk is going to be regulated as
genetically engineer so different places
have different regulations and they are
all struggling with acting
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so that's that's one of the things
that people are debating now and would
it be more acceptable to people if you
just use for example it whispered a
pretty variation with industry seems
rather than reaching beyond those
boundaries but you know I have no senses
there are people hurt when that will be
reassuring sound and accidentally
consuming something from a bacterium and
I thought it was just eating food and
never mind that in nature that does
happen there's well bacteria and viruses
that we know can insert their genetic
material for sure yeah yeah we're stuck
that's marketing I absolutely hurt that
moment some of these are people who
would be reassured by that and then
there are feeling we'll just think oh
now they're taking this technology
actually look like and are putting it in
products where I can't even tell you
know there's this except if it works and
Destin anyways so that so you know I'm
just going to say I'm I'm having issues
answering questions at this point if
that works for you
[Music]
population yeah
beats are not one of the insects that is
affected by the bacillus thuringiensis
so consequently that person doesn't
really affect me either
that's one of the reasons people really
like it what is an organic insecticide
as a conventional insecticide and
message many different races its action
spectrum is pretty narrative confined to
the lettuce the characters come and the
peels and different duties work on
particular species so I guess what I was
wondering about is there's a great lack
of understanding of all of this and
there's a lot of emotion in it and so
what what does Cornell do to address
that because I think at Cornell we have
people who are absolutely pro GMO and I
think there's a lot of people who are
probably absolutely against it and
that's what we could all do but this
Cornell have programs that that that
that interpret this and extend it out I
mean can you
on those issues that is a variety people
that point out - speaking publishing
educating is educational so i services
our goal is to help people understand
the technology and what both its risks
ended its benefits and risks are because
there are a lot of people talk about
only one or only together our job is not
to take sides but to help people
understand it so they can make a better
important choice of their own I think
the other thing that is my
responsibility here is to be as
thoughtful as we can about where that
has arisen I live so I say that as a
scientist you know it comes back to me
because they and I was speaking to an
audience it was a competitive way
without genetic engineer crops and food
safety which is always a big concern to
people since I'm not going to get to
those slides I'll just say right now
that scientifically there's no evidence
of any of the commercialized genetic
engineered crops have anything about
risks related to food safety but one of
the roots of the put in up here
exactly right rady stricken and at the
end and said so how do we know this
isn't the next tranche as you know it
it's a really good question because
we've had a history but many exams
were developed because people willing to
be theta might be better for us
what about people's over there you know
we didn't apply CFCs where the spray
that we just made a really good
interpretation so sometimes things need
tying to find so I would just say
however as scientists it's also a
combination to have a certain degree of
humility and a huge degree of
forethought fullness to see as best we
can where the problems might live and
that's it
y'all should also know nobody funds
research that will examine unintended
consequences so how do you do that
design so that there there is the edge
may inherit examination of data looks
quite carefully at potential
and they have you know a fair amount
about that leaders you know you know
with major allergen to certain kind of
structures and and families of chemicals
that I tend to see together today the
other thing they do is they always know
tax data or in vitro so in a petri dish
great breakdown with human digestive
enzymes then the argument there is if it
breaks down any more slowly than in the
normal routine that you would find
that's a red flag simply because the
longer something is in your digestive
system the more chance you have to have
any kind of a reaction to it whether
it's Jennifer just irritation plan so
things that break down people only get
red-flagged and they will not be
approved until that is examined and
understood so that's in a bit the
emergency question I think is handled
probably the best weekend with that
because the only way to really help
[Music]
[Music]
we do get to hybrids that don't
propagate truth you know they think you
could say this even in work is mass
right I know there are also several is
particularly in ornamentals we're going
to say clever more they're necessarily
trying to exceed so they just eat
whatever so he said you can read to
sterols there is any genetically
controlled the sterile traits to genetic
control so we put it absolutely both by
reading organization and engineering
change that we don't yet have a good way
thank heavens breathing truth that you
know strangely
[Music]
[Music]
better than I can
I don't know and I don't know how to
incite questions until someone gets
something approved that they actually
want to try my understanding at the
Bluebird oversees that it isn't simply
that great color and so really doesn't
announce right but I would also say that
there's a lot of scope for three
different colors and then finally say
I'm smart you under the table because in
Section plans they have to sell to each
one of us
[Music]
so here is the intersection it must be
broken on that vehicle right along with
many of them requirements and that is
true but the fact that it's not genetic
engineer just saw a matinee again so get
away this is quick but you know there's
a
[Music]
what we're looking at in their part are
they want for beauty but it's nothing
that affects their health unless they're
planning my papers so I think there's no
surprises in reality and it does it's
maybe wonder for a long time about
engineering or nonetheless because I
think that with the area where they're
less concerned the original concept was
in ornamental it was a pine tree and in
engineering it was marketed never even
necessarily have to plant I don't know
but they engineer different issue from
the fiberglass the luciferase gene and
if the lipstick race team and the fire
plane has the right chemical to work on
it will produce lights so they've done
that you need to the plankton and if you
watered it with the right chemical rusev
planting the tree fruit lights
[Music]
I will say is very cruel process right
now so this that process they're going
to string that doesn't produce what's
the cost the actual genetic engineering
which is
[Music]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu